[Music]
Salam alaikum guys were wrapping up here
and I just experienced a very memorable
moment so I'm finishing up my talk and
as people are about to leave I ask very
important question give the invitation
and try to remember to do this so I ask
is anybody want to accept Islam now
Chris who you'll meet in a moment
not only was Chris outside of the room
he was almost outside of the building
but he heard me and that was what's
really fascinating here is the timing
and it just confirms that nothing is by
chance if I would have just said this a
minute later or maybe not at all he
would have been gone so that was the
beautiful thing that it's on us to give
that invitation and then it's up to the
person if they're gonna give birth to
what's already inside of them and the
call of Islam is what we share these
memorable moments because people who are
out there starting bad trends so many
crazy things out there but just to show
how easy it is to be thankful and
grateful to the one who created you and
hopefully we can stimulate and motivate
more people to come and give birth to
what's already inside them like Chris
did so this is his his moment his
life-changing moment his Shahada enjoy
tsunami I said is there anyone who would
think that someone who raised their hand
not even in the world Chris was outside
of the room I said I said is there
anyone here who'd like to accept
what you do you guys see that six months
so you understood like you have the six
articles with faith really simple to
believe in one and only one God the
Angels the messengers the books never
revealed to the vessel purity of
judgment and the destiny destiny yeah
it's a lifelong learning and then you
have to find pillars one of which is to
test them when you believe this that
there's only one God then I'm not going
to worship anything in creation except
God I'm not working to worship Muhammad
I'm not going to worship Jesus
I'm not going to worship a stick a stone
above a man a woman an angel a dead
person agree money materialism jcj whole
Kardashian the Kardashian shop
I'm not going to worship any of these
things but I'm going to worship the one
who created I'm gonna worship the
Creator
that's Islam yeah that's the first step
that's the shadow then after that you
have obviously the career you start
fasting and all these things take a
little bit of time you start to
implement them and you see that
talk about that love right when it's a
learning process it takes time but the
first thing is to acknowledge to submit
to what's the truth because many people
they experience the truth but they end
up they they feel it damndest and above
the Nate don't have the courage here
the courageous individual because you're
stepping forward
so the shahadat goes like this because
it's in your heart you believe it and
now is to express it with your tongue is
to declare that there is no state in
arabic and the simple meaning is that
there's nothing worthy worship there's
no God except God is no God except Allah
Mohammad is the Messenger of Allah and
this is what I said in my talk
this will automatically include Jesus
name
[Music]
are you ready assume there was nothing
that there's nothing worthy of worship
worthy of worship except the creator
Allah except the Creator Allah and I
bear witness that Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon Muhammad
blessed baby the apartment upon is the
slave servant and messanger of Allah is
a slave servant and messanger of those
yes and Jesus Jesus is a Messenger of
Allah as a Messenger of Allah
[Applause]
[Music]
I need someone right now to dedicate not
just to come and give him some hugs
but exchange the phone number someone's
going to be like a guardian angel
someone that he can connect with this is
your brother this is your brother now
Islam and I need you guys to exchange
the checkout market to help him to help
nurture this to help him grow because we
see too many people they come in and
they lose they don't know what their
family this is our family now
[Music]
ha there's only one bed and Jesus was
his messenger Allah Allah Allah there's
only one bed and Moses was his messenger
Allah Allah there's only one was his
messenger Allah Allah there's only one
was his messenger Allah Allah there's
only one God and he created
[Music]
[Music]